[Music]
in tonight's whatever happened to
segment the women's political movement
the most recent iteration began shortly
after president Trump's inauguration now
its effects are showing up on ballots
everywhere this midterm season tonight
correspondent I need Anita Vogel looks
at where the movement has been and maybe
where it's going they came from all
walks of life to protest Donald Trump's
election women disappointed the would-be
first female president fell short at the
polls and so a movement was born we are
absolutely thrilled to see so many women
running for office in 2018 there's no
way to put the genie back in the bottle
and once that women's March happen and
women seem to understand that they
didn't just need to March they needed to
vote and then they needed to run for
office from the possible first Native
American woman to be elected to Congress
to a young community organizer in New
York no one had ever heard of female
candidates are now lining up for the
upcoming midterms a total of four
hundred seventy six women have filed to
run for the House of Representatives
more than three hundred are still
running on the Senate side 54 have filed
with 36 still in the hunt
62 women have entered governor's races
and more than 2,000 are targeting seats
in state legislatures we need women in
every single position so more women are
heading to the classroom to learn how to
run for office and how to win what we're
teaching them is how to really speak
with power how to talk about why you're
in the best person
the job how to resonate with voters how
to raise that money I've seen what women
can do Erin Velarde heads-up vote run
lead which attracts mostly progressive
candidates I'm really young I'm 22 years
old so I've got a lot of time to figure
out how exactly I want to say what I
want to say how can I best put my
message out there Republican women have
their own groups in California it's the
Marion Bergesen series I don't think
anyone should ever assume that it's easy
to run for office whether they're a
Democrat or a Republican
Rita tope Allion took the class and won
her latest primary I've done this four
times that I could almost be a joke
people could say oh it she's running
again but you know what each time I run
I learn but the key is turning out votes
and while there are a record number of
women running for office this year
mostly Democrats as of 2016 only about
25% of elected positions in the u.s.
were held by women Brett I need a thank
you